Speaker 1: As many of you know, there's this cadre
of particularly extreme Republican members of
Congress right now. Often we talk about Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Boebert, Madison Cawthorn as
three of the sort of newer, radical Republicans.
Now I could not care less about Madison Cawthorn
personal life. It turns out that Madison Cawthorn
is getting divorced from his wife after a year of
marriage. I could not care less. I just don't
care, and I wouldn't even be talking about it,
except for the fact that in the context of this
divorce, a very, very strange video has come up
in which Madison Cawthorn explains the story of
how he met his wife, and it involves attending a
CrossFit competition that didn't really exist
after visiting Russia and meeting someone.
And it all just stinks to high heaven of
Russian kompromat or some kind of honeypot
intelligence operation. Now, I want to be
clear, I'm not saying that's what it is.
It's just incredible that Cawthorn himself
seems to have no self-awareness whatsoever,
that the story of how they met is just a little
bit weird. Yahoo News has an article about it
where they write. A video has resurfaced of
Madison Cawthorn saying he met his soon to be
ex-wife at a fake CrossFit competition organized
by a U.S. Army captain that he met in Russia.
The tale involves a casino in St. Petersburg,
Russia, that led to a fake CrossFit competition
in Miami, which Cawthorn referred to as a sham
to introduce him to the woman who would become
his fiancee. Now this is an 18 month old video.
It's resurfaced. I'd never seen this before.
And he talks about going to Russia on a vacation.
The story is all very, very strange. So let's look
at the video and this already with nearly three
million views because it's just so bizarre.
Speaker 4: And so we took the risk to do that
surgery. And so when I decided to do that,
I said, Well, doctor, let me go on one last trip
just in case I'm not going to be able to ever get
on an airplane again. And then we said, OK, we'll
get well and you'll be in a lot of pain. I said,
It's worth it. So me and a bunch of my friends
we went to, we got to go over to the over Ogutu,
very close to Russia.
Speaker 1: We got. So even here,
it's a little weird because it sounds like he's
going to say something else. And then he says,
very close to Russia. Let
me just go back there, OK?
Speaker 4: You got to go over to the over to very
close to Russia. We got went to Sweden and Norway
and we had just an incredible vacation. It was
great. I was in a lot of pain the whole time,
but it was wonderful.
Speaker 1: So he says
they went to Sweden and Norway,
Speaker 4: but then we got on a
boat and went in to St Petersburg in Russia.
Speaker 1: OK, now I'm already suspicious of
this story. Because what he's saying could
be true. He says they went to Sweden and
Norway and got on a boat to Russia. Most
people who do the ferry to St. Petersburg
go from Helsinki, Finland. Look at a map and
you'll see geographically. Norway to Russia
makes no sense. I think you can get
a boat. I think it's multiple days.
Sweden to Saint Petersburg. There is a ferry.
I think it's close to 40 hours and could
make. Did they could they have taken a 35 40
hour ferry? Maybe not that many people do it.
Typically, people go Helsinki to St Petersburg and
you see that it's much closer. So his hesitation
combined with saying then we got on a boat,
it already is sort of weird, but that's
nothing compared to where it's going to go.
Speaker 4: And, you know, we just decided to
take a hundred dollars each and go into a casino
and see how it went. And you know, I ended up
meeting an American there who was a captain in the
army and who is originally from Miami. And so we
hit it off, create a really great relationship
and stay in contact for about a year and a half
until later, I was down in Miami for work. And
he he texted me and said, Hey, would you like
to come compete across the competition? And so
I was like, I can laugh and say, Well, time,
I'm in a wheelchair. I obviously can't do
CrossFit. And he said, we'll just do the
pull up section. I was like, OK, sounds good. And
so I show up. But anyways, it all was a sham. It
was a fake CrossFit competition. You just want
me to put me in the same room with the girl who
is eventually going to become my fiance. And so
we him her and I hit it off, and it was that it
was really the magical relationship ever since.
Speaker 1: Now, if that doesn't seem extremely
bizarre to anybody else than he does, any of the
story makes sense to anybody. He was in Sweden
and Norway and took a boat to St. Petersburg,
which is already something very few people do
at a casino. He happens to meet a U.S. Army
captain who stays in touch with him at a Russian
casino invites him to a CrossFit competition. Why
that guy would think, Hey, you know what? I can't
just tell him, I've got someone I want you to meet
down here. He has to create a sham. The belief
of a sham CrossFit competition to get him down
there to meet a woman. Why did this woman want
to meet him? What did the woman know about him and
what? None of the story makes sense. Now again,
we don't know anything, but it is a wacky and
bizarre story, and maybe at some point we'll
learn more about what the back story here is.
But needless to say, that relationship is ending.